hey everybody it's monday yeah and that
means we're talking about a haunting
yeah another one of our little haunting
uh episodes these are these are always
fun yeah this one is uh from season
seven and i think we uh
you posted that right you gave them last
night i did yeah because i think we said
on the show i thought somebody told me
that the one that you were talking about
was called the calling but then which is
from season four but then when i looked
that one up that one it wasn't that so
like actually it's weird because i had
thought the one that you were talking
about with uh joseph the freed slave
ghost
um i was like i thought that was like
earlier like i thought it was from
season three or four so i kept going
through all the lists and being like why
the [ __ ] can i find it because it's
season seven yeah i said on that show i
think it was seven or eight
did you remember that no i don't know
yeah i said i think it's later i think
it's seven or eight i don't remember
that yeah what was it called again it's
called demon's revenge yeah yeah demons
revenge that's what i mean it's like so
i i'm never gonna
yeah i'm never gonna remember that name
yeah
there is a demon in it but oh [ __ ] i'm
sorry yeah it's one of the good ones on
season seven yeah season seven isn't
like a strong season from what i
remember i didn't go back and look at it
but this is a strong episode it's like
something that you'd get from season two
or three you know around like that and
it had one of the scariest [ __ ]
ghosts in it
was uh
what's he doing what are you knock
something over i don't know what was the
name of that ghost joseph joseph joseph
yeah
and joseph shows up as a damn
freed slave from like the 1800s with his
cowboy hat on and his down white shirt
and
saying this is my house you know get it
this is my house and just his eyes are
glowing and everything it's pretty
[ __ ] spooky he's one of the better
ghosts in the hole in the whole yeah
they did like a real effective uh makeup
and wardrobe on there that made him like
real spooky yeah so then uh you see him
and then they give some backstory they
do an investigation they try to figure
out who this is and then they uh come
across what they what they believe is a
demon now you know i wasn't there so i
can't really make any
i can't really throw my two cents in
that with any kind of like you know
certainty
i can just say i think it was a good
story
and it's actually why i forgot how good
this is
and um
the witnesses sound pretty credible you
know i mean something happened i just
don't know what it was
don't matter something paranormal i was
trying to find this actual house because
as usual the house that they put on the
show is not the actual house but
i couldn't really find the house however
i did find a really long write-up by you
know the lady that they interviewed on
the show that was like the head of the
paranormal investigation team that came
there yeah uh she did a really long
write up on her blog you're like in the
video next door no i'm not because
that's
it's fine your face is like getting cut
off
it's how many times do i have to tell
you oh that's right it's not the same
yeah
i have to tell him that like every time
so i got the chat moved over there i
thought that was yeah because i have to
have room for the notes
you know
this thing isn't uh so anyway what was i
talking about oh [ __ ] i don't know man i
thought [ __ ] was [ __ ] up no it's not
[ __ ] up what was she saying this is
the same place that i always say yeah so
it's like i should know the camera's not
moved yeah um but yes but
now i forgot what i was saying what was
she talking about people damn it oh no i
[ __ ] it was oh oh oh um
oh but i did find like the lady that was
the paranormal investigator
she wrote a big long
blog post
about this case
and so she had like a bunch of other
information that they didn't really put
on the show and she was kind of talking
a little bit about she thought the show
did a pretty good job of um you know of
portraying what it was
so we'll get into that like toward the
end like we'll just kind of go through
the show and then i'll say like what she
put on the thing now i will note
that
in the blog post she had put links to
some videos that they had recorded
during their investigation
and
they really weren't all that impressive
but i'll kind of get into that later
they never are like all those paranormal
ones like unless they're faked yeah this
is taking place at a farm that has a
barn
20 acres which is pretty big
animals and stuff
and i have a part-time background and
all that you know i grew up in the uh in
the horse industry when i was a little
boy you know my mother was a california
champion [ __ ] uh equestrian writer uh
[ __ ] english equestrian over in
california
and um
so i grew up around horses and uh when
when pickens gets slim back in the day
uh you know what i mean if [ __ ]
military [ __ ] wasn't hyping her
she threw her own toy and chased it
i'd end up
and then you end up either going back to
kitchen work which i love working in
kitchens and or or barn work in florida
i'd work in there's so many barns here
yeah he was working in a barn when i met
well like i didn't actually meet you you
were in the barn but you had that job
there yeah i love working with animals
and barns you know [ __ ] a lot of
my background is [ __ ] hunters and
[ __ ]
growing up as a [ __ ] hunter and
everything so people say well damn you
hate animals no i love animals nothing
but clean kills it's all just food
creating food and then you know
basically kind of like halal slaughter
and make sure that [ __ ] everybody
nobody knows what's going on it's all
[ __ ]
not cruel you know what i mean they
don't know what's happening so
even even things that aren't pets you
got to respect all animals um
you know that was kind of like a native
american way [ __ ] of hunting but um
so what happens in this some of it i can
i can kind of give my two cents on some
of the things that happen in this barn
may have not have been
may not have been uh paranormal
yeah get it
chasing the [ __ ] toy mouse
it's just cracking me up seeing her a
little running around so if i
if i chime in about something about you
know barn work you know and animal
husbandry and [ __ ] like that's because i
have experience in it
um so uh just priming you guys for that
but i liked it because i could kind of
relate to it you know i mean with the
[ __ ] barn aspect of it and
the the place that they showed on the
episode looked cool 20 acres pretty
[ __ ] big it was a nice looking place
but the thing is like i really did look
to find this list and probably if you
had more time because i didn't have a
lot of time today but i did spend quite
a bit of time like trying to see if i
could find it um because i was like
maybe it has a reputation for being
haunted but i couldn't really find
anything that because it seems like
there's a lot of these kind of like old
plantation house type things like in
that area
and i even looked on like zillow and
stuff i'm like where is there like a 20
acre
farmhouse in this town that's you know
for rent or whatever but yeah i couldn't
really find anything yeah he had round
pens and [ __ ] and and and pastures
and
look like in the in the one that they
showed there were stuff for horses
chicken coops he said he had chickens
and rabbits he just said he had one
rabbit one rabbit that was basically
like his daughter's pet yeah
i miss having chickens access to
chickens but can use some of that barn i
once took care of over there dr matt's
bar uh barn was all you could eat free
eggs
those chickens they made more eggs than
they could eat than that home could eat
so i just i could walk out with like
five dozen eggs
no problem next day there'd be
another seven dozen [ __ ] eggs there
was a lot of chickens man
remember those things yeah
yeah yeah we just get all kind of eggs
from yeah
like i said they didn't they had the
family that had the chickens it's like
look it's like here just take them yeah
they're like taking them to them
they were gone they'd go overseas a lot
you know they'd go to the middle east
and uh you know and or egypt for uh for
a vacation and i'd watch the place for
months at a time take care of the foot
take care of their horses and
uh make sure everything was mowed and
you know just make sure security was
kept up and
and uh that was a good barn i loved i
loved taking care of that place that was
a nice place yeah they had a couple
goats too
that were super cute yeah so i was
caretaker of dr matt's barn his mom
built orlando hospital from a very
wealthy family it was like going to
disneyland
private roads going through it you'd
never find the place if you didn't know
where it was
big ass [ __ ] house all right
then it's like one of these houses like
it looks like an english manor conda
well no english colonial kind of
plantation style manner it wasn't that
old though you know yeah it didn't look
better no but it was made with all wood
you know expensive wood and
grand pianos and spiral staircases and
tile on the floor real tiles you know um
carports
where you could pull in and have your
chauffeur let you out of your car and
that kind of [ __ ] you know it was it was
nice his barn was
bigger than this house
you know
uh
50 how many probably 12 horses 12 12
stalls probably
probably about yeah i remember i think
it was twelve stalls yes because
it wasn't there 12 stalls shower racks
looking and everything so you know and
then the chicken coops and [ __ ]
turkeys
all kinds of adventures happen jenny
would come and [ __ ] visit me while i
was working
you know play with the goat play with
the goats riding around on the damn
tractors
cutting mowing the damn fields
it's fun
i guess they still live there don't they
yeah they used to live there
it's not that it's not that far from our
old house actually i don't know it's
like it's not that far from here well
yeah i know but i'm just saying it was a
lot closer to our old yes i think it was
only like a mile from our old house
about two miles two yeah two miles from
one would last yeah that's what i
thought but you had to know where it was
yeah because it was on like a private
road yep there'd be a road that would
just end and then on the side there'd be
a dirt road just going off into the
forest and you would never know what
that was and you had to go down there
and wait yeah
yeah and you would dance like a thing
back there yeah yeah
oscar says jenny you're glowing yeah
it's all that phosphorous and like
that's what it is
jenny's getting in shape man
she's [ __ ] getting that figure
[ __ ] set steady man it's looking good
getting all bombshell riding 20 miles on
that goddamn bike again today
plus i've only eaten the only things
i've eaten today i've eaten one hot dog
and one granola bar that's all i've
eaten all day waste came in
got the booty big boobs yeah she's
looking good
zach says this episode was kind of
unsatisfying to me i love the stock
scream when the mom finds the dead
animals yeah
yeah that was pretty great and the
glasses on the little girl were ugly as
then oh i kind of liked them they were
ugly but in a cute ugly kind of way when
we get the little girl when we get to
the dead animals
i did i doubted that i don't think that
was paranormal
it might not have been now and now
i will say too that in concerning the
dead animals there were actually more
dead animals than they showed on the
show yeah
so that they didn't put in the shower
how about we talking well i don't know i
don't know no it wasn't all chickens it
was like some other stuff but it was
smaller animals
for the most part yeah yeah
yeah they're they had a horse but i
don't think the horse got killed there's
a lot of exponents but there were some
stuff about the horse where like the
horse was like didn't want to go in the
barn and [ __ ] like that but and i think
it's weird because
on the show
like they implied that they had a horse
because they had like a
sound effect of like a horse winning but
they never like specifically said that
they had a horse and i don't think they
ever should or no i guess they did like
at some point but they didn't say the
horse got killed because i don't think
it did but
yeah they did actually have a horse in
the barn too yeah but as far as i know
it did it dr matt had four or five
horses and then he had some boarders who
boarded in there like three more of them
ponies and [ __ ] too
they were all english thoroughbreds nice
nice horses
[ __ ] wash rack in there farrier would
come by
it was just like it's like running a
business it is if you can't just do that
[ __ ]
like some of these people think you just
do that [ __ ] and lay back on your
laurels and just [ __ ] you know do it
as a side thing no
it's a full-time business even if you're
not making any food
you got to mow the lawn you can hire
somebody but then all the landscaping
and everything and
upkeep and maintenance it's constant we
were just talking about this the other
day i said you know i have always
thought that even if you know
if i won the lottery which would be
awesome universe uh by the way
um i don't think that i would do and i'm
not like [ __ ] on people that want to
do this like oh i'm going to win the
lottery and i want 20 acres and horses
and blah blah but in a big mansion and
i'm not averse to like having a nice
house but to be honest with you like the
bigger the house is like the more it
just seems like a [ __ ] job like
keeping track of it i'm like you gotta
hire people to like do the landscaping
you gotta hire people to clean it you
gotta do this that the other thing and
it just seems like like i said it seems
like a job and i'm like no thank you i
would rather just kind of like live
somewhere i said you know what i can
totally understand people that have a
[ __ ] ton of money and don't even like
really have a permanent house they just
like live in hotels like in whatever
city they want to go to i'm like that
kind of sounds more like me i'm more
like a low maintenance kind of gal for
me the best thing would be a
[ __ ] top-notch
cool ass
cabin like somebody's hunting lodge but
you know classy all right that's off the
grid it's got its own power production
solar it's on well
its own sewage
and there isn't any really lawns or
anything like that but you can have
chickens and
a little garden in the back and it's out
in the middle of [ __ ] nowhere so if
anything went wrong nobody would know
you were there you know it looked like
one of those things you see in colorado
or something yeah you know something
like that big picture windows made out
of glass
where the end of the world ever happened
your main protection would be that
obscurity nobody ever find you just out
of nowhere
i'm just saying i would rather go the
low maintenance route i don't really
want a big estate that needs a whole
crew of people to keep it running
because that just seems like way too
much trouble that's why to me like the
whole
the whole nice thing about having money
is not having to do all of that crap
yeah you know that's why i said like a
lodge or a cabin because you know that
doesn't have any of that you might have
rocks around it in a [ __ ] road a
gravel road running up to it like i said
i'd probably just live out in town trees
you know it's like i probably just live
in hotel rooms or get like a really
really nice like penthouse condo
somewhere like in a building where
everything where i don't have any
outdoor or anything
like and everything's kind of like taken
care of for you and you can just like
walk to wherever you want to go i would
rather i like much rather have something
like that
deborah hockett is here tom and jen you
two look marvelous thank you very much
man we must look nicer today than usual
i feel sick
that's what i was going to say you don't
even feel all that good and i'm on it
the last few days too i've been kind of
like not feeling all that well either
so nothing it's not you know covet or
flu or anything like that but you know
it's nothing like that but i'm just
saying
yeah i haven't really felt 100 percent
lately either but i'm kind of feeling
better today but you've kind of been
feeling crappy the last couple days yeah
i'm transforming into a minotaur
i i understand how difficult yeah that's
right formed into a minotaur
like i said that new [ __ ] [ __ ] got to
adjust to that
give me a headache
yeah a little bit yeah well you thought
too that it was like dehydration because
you're not you're not like me i me i
have like a big glass of ice water or
sugar-free iced tea
next to my computer at all times as soon
as it's empty i run down to the room and
get more ice and get more water or tea
and i always have a full one going
because i have to be drinking something
all the time because my i have like
[ __ ] cotton mouth man yeah
like my mouth dries out okay we got a
pretty good crowd in there all right
good yeah zach says uh if i won the
lottery i'd get a regular suburban home
but my two indulgences would be a home
theater and an indoor pool yeah i get
that i wouldn't mind having a home
theater actually uh and an indoor pool
would be nice too but like i said the
more things
i don't know i just kind of feel like
i've lived so long i've lived like 50
years without all that kind of stuff so
a lot of the stuff it just seems like
more trouble than it's worth so it's
like i don't really know if i would use
it enough to like justify the expense of
it or you know taking care of it so the
older i get the more i'm like would i
really
want to
you know
either do the [ __ ] myself like to
maintain that or hire somebody to do it
and then have to manage that situation
and it's like i'd really have to kind of
like weigh the pros and cons of it you
know what i mean
because i'm just like i'm not lazy but
a lot of stuff i feel like is just kind
of unnecessary
i don't know unless you're just making
unnecessary work for yourself so like i
said i'm not you know like the barn that
he used to work at it was like yeah it
was this big mansion and they had like
all these horses and chickens and it was
like this massive massive thing and they
like i said they ran a business on the
side where they were bored people's
horses and people came over and did like
horse you know
horse riding like training and stuff
like that and if that's what they want
to do that's cool but it's like i would
never want to
manage like all of the [ __ ] that had to
do with that because even if you don't
do it yourself you still got to manage
the people that do it so i don't know it
just seems like too much work to me you
know what i mean
uh zach says when i was younger i
thought alcohol and coffee were adult
drinks now i realize the actual adult
drink is water
i am constantly shocked at how many
people just do not drink water i
i don't know i guess i grew up because i
grew up i wasn't i'll drink soda but i'm
not like a big fan of it i don't have to
have it if somebody said you can never
drink soda ever again i'd be like all
right i don't really care that much
about it and i never have like even when
i was a kid
and it's weird because the rest of my
family were just kind of like we have to
have coke all the time and i'm just like
why it's you know i don't like it but um
yeah so when i was a kid pretty much all
i would drink was water
right out of the tap uh milk i drank a
lot of milk like ice milk or sometimes
orange juice or apple juice or grape
juice if we had it which we didn't
usually but other than that i didn't
drink it but
and i still just drink mostly water
you know i have coffee in the morning
and then all day i usually drink water
or sometimes tom will make sugar-free
tea and i'll drink that too but
other than that i don't drink soda
nothing like that and booze obviously
i like
booze um let's see danny rowling said
tom sort of looks like the pilot from
the episode the calling at a quick
glimpse in the face just saying okay i
don't remember that one
yeah we didn't watch that we well the
weird thing okay so we watched
this episode obviously last night and i
watched it again
this morning because i usually watch
them twice like the first time i watch
it like and pay attention and then the
second time i watch it and then like
take notes about it and then try to find
uh you know real [ __ ] that's you know in
the if there's anything online i can
find about the case
so uh so we did that but then like after
that we're like oh yeah we bought season
eight on amazon prime
so we watched a couple more
even though i was kind of like well
maybe i shouldn't because then i'll get
like confused but it kind of happens
yeah because sometimes you're just kind
of like wait that happened on that one
but because i went through and watched
it again today and took notes i
shouldn't get confused about it yeah
um hugo says hi guys you know i've never
seen this haunting tv show still i enjoy
your company every monday on my 3 p.m
work break with an ice cold coke
yeah i mean you don't have to have seen
it
it's more fun i guess if you've seen it
but
i don't know i kind of feel like you
probably don't have to have seen it to
enjoy the show some just listen to stuff
yeah that's all right
um all right so as i mentioned this
one's called demon's revenge demon's
revenge
season seven episode one this was
actually a good one to start out on i
don't remember a lot of the episodes
from the season so i don't know if this
is the best one we'll probably get back
to them at some point
so this took place in franklin virginia
and i'm assuming that that's the real
place because it was the real people and
they used their real names and blahdy
blah and when i found the [ __ ] on the um
on the paranormal investigators website
they did also they did say it was
franklin virginia so i guess that's
where it is franklin virginia
interestingly is kind of like not even
in a county it's like its own thing it's
like a city in a county at the same time
from what i could determine yeah because
i was like i said i was trying to see if
i could find the real house but i
couldn't find it
so it's this 200 year farmhouse now this
took place
uh what the events of this show took
place in the summer of 2008.
so you got a guy named billy i think his
last name is quattle bomb yeah quad a
bomb i think that's what it was like i'm
not sure like in my notes i'm not sure
if i spelled it right like i put a
little that's what it was i think yeah i
think that's what it was it was quite a
bomb and he has a girlfriend named
tiffany i think it was mckinnon or
mckenna it almost sounded like the
anthony called the narrator i thought he
said mckenna but then when i looked it
up on another site they spelled it
mckinnon
so
maybe he was just pronounced so it could
be either one of those things i'm not
really sure
now the two of them had been dating for
only five months
and decide to move in together like i
said this wasn't they didn't buy this
place they just rented it which you know
considering what ended up happening was
probably a good idea because they would
have been like really [ __ ] if they'd
they'd bought it
um so yeah it's this big
you know essentially like an old
plantation house it's on 20 acres uh
this big farmhouse and there's like an
old barn on the property as well
so they say that this area is you know
plantations mostly like going back as
far as the 1600s mostly tobacco cotton
plantations stuff like that
so billy has an eight-year-old daughter
named georgia who lives with them so
they move in uh two no i don't you know
he's i'm assuming that's from like a
former marriage
and he's very happy about this place
because he's always wanted to raise
georgia out in the country i don't
really know where these two are from
originally i'm assuming they're from the
area
so georgia was also on the show like
grown up obviously
and she said she really really liked the
house at first because it was like way
bigger than where they came from and it
was like really quiet out there and blah
blah so there's kind of a creepy scene
near the beginning of the show with
georgia kind of peeking into like a dark
room or a closet or something like that
and there's like some dark shadow you
know how they do on a haunting when they
want to imply
that you know oh they weren't alone or
someone was watching them or something
like that they'll put something in and
then they'll put like some little shadow
going like behind the person it's like
the person didn't say they saw that but
they're just trying to like illustrate
that i guess because at this point like
the narrator is like you know but they
aren't alone you know what i mean so she
didn't say she saw anything or heard
anything weird because i don't think
that georgia even saw her heard anything
weird until like later on this seemed
like it was one of those situations
where
um the mom tiffany she was kind of like
well i guess that wasn't really her mom
but like the the lady she was the one
that kind of saw most of the stuff and
then the other she didn't really see the
stuff until later on
so the family at this point they have he
said they started out they had half a
dozen chickens two ducks and a rabbit
one thing they didn't say and i don't
know if they thought this would be too
upsetting but um
they also had a puppy named rebel
which they didn't say on the show but
which the uh investigator said on the
thing
now the puppy didn't die in the great
animal killing thing that happened but
he did run way down the driveway and get
hit by a car oh and killed so there's
that well they know they didn't include
that because they knew that that wasn't
paranormal yeah and plus also nobody
wants to see like a [ __ ] puppy get
killed either come on that's that's
terrible
um you know i was upset enough about the
bunny getting killed for christ's sake
so tiffany and georgia are like really
into having all the animals they keep
him in the old barn on the property
tiffany at first like the first thing
she kind of like says about it was that
she thought the old barn was kind of
creepy okay so she said
she said that when you went in there it
was like really weirdly
silent
like i'm assuming she means like it's
some kind of silent that's like a
paranormal like an unnatural type of
silence that seemed like what she was
getting at
so one day she's in there you know doing
whatever she's doing and the door
closed on her
like you know the main barn door and she
couldn't get out like the door was stuck
so she's like sitting there banging out
like hey the [ __ ] door's stuck and i
can't get out and like you know nobody
could hear her or whatever
so eventually she does get out and she's
like oh maybe the wind just blew it shut
but she's pretty sure that that's not
what happened because she was like
really really weirded out like the whole
time that she was in the barn
um she said also the whole time she was
in there she said you really had the
feeling that
you shouldn't look behind you like
because there was maybe something there
and like maybe she should get the [ __ ]
out like she said it was a very very
strong feeling been there done that
danny rowling said um in the sixth and
seventh season of a haunting do they
still use any of the previous homes from
the first four seasons at all like they
always do it looks like it they probably
did i imagine like i said that they had
that they had like a
stable of houses that they would keep
reusing because i'd imagine like people
were actually living in those houses and
you'd have to like get permission either
or the houses were empty you know and
they just kind of had i don't really
know but it does seem to me that they do
generally try to use houses that are
near
the ones that they're
you know what i mean like in the same
town or whatever is the ones that
they're talking about like even though
obviously they're not the same ones
zack says i also think the chick playing
the mom
gave the best performance i've seen on
this show so far i guess on this one
yeah
yeah she yeah she was pretty good like i
said all the acting on this is like
actually pretty solid i've never seen
anybody that stood out as being like a
terrible actor no these are all very
very solid actors yeah if they're not
solid they're entertaining yeah
where's that raccoon dude it's [ __ ]
entertaining and he he was he was pretty
solid this episode i kind of feel like
i even wrote up my notes this episode
has a little bit of a where is that
raccoon moment um it's not exactly the
same but it's kind of the same spirit
anyway so we'll kind of get into that uh
you know what i mean because you know
[Music]
to like just put that in there all right
so um so a week after they move in
billy is of course working late because
the man is never there when this scary
[ __ ] happens he's always working late
and georgia is not home either because
she's visiting her grandparents so
tiffany is alone in the house for the
first time since they've moved in
she said she was like in the it looked
like she was in the dining room and she
was like changing um a light bulb like
in the chandelier thing like over the
table
and she said that the air started
feeling very thick
and she said it suddenly got really
really cold even though it was
summertime and it was hot outside
she said she heard something like
footsteps
and then all the lights kind of like
flickered and went out
and she said it was really scary
so she calls billy and billy at first
he's a real dick about it like at first
he just kind of like teases her about it
saying oh this the house is teasing you
or talking to you i think he said
something like that or the house is
messing with you and he just like kind
of laughed it off and she's like bro
this shit's not funny like this is like
scary as [ __ ]
and uh she said
that she was like panicking and she was
really creeped out and because he kept
like just making fun of her she was like
yeah [ __ ] this [ __ ] and she said she
just like grabbed the keys to the truck
and just like jumped in the truck and
like got the [ __ ] out for a little while
because she said it was really really
creepy
so over the next few weeks she says uh
she's just trying to live with it um
trying to convince herself that she's
just imagining things she said now we
were otherwise very happy in the house
so it was easier to deal with at first
um although at night like [ __ ] gets like
super scary
so one night apparently uh she starts
hearing kind of like banging coming from
downstairs she tries to wake billy up
yeah but he's not evident
he doesn't wake up right and i'm like
okay whatever useless [ __ ] so
but well i mean the way this comes out
it's not exactly what you think it is so
she says the banging gets louder and
louder and more intense as she walks
down the staircase right she said that
it was so dark that she couldn't see
anything like for some reason she wasn't
able to turn the lights on
and she said she had to open the front
door to see what was going on
so she kind of looks out she goes out on
the porch and is looking around and she
doesn't see anything at first but then
like she turns to one side and there's
joseph the ghost right standing on the
porch
and he's out of the door yeah the door
opening and he comes at her like he just
busts through the door
and she kind of like falls on her back
on the floor and he's kind of like
towering over here and he starts
screaming this is my house yeah then
like he's super creepy well he doesn't
really bust through the door though well
it sounds like you know breaking it
doesn't really matter because well she
said that like on the show though that's
why i wrote it down
um what they show is her falling down
and him coming in through the doorway
and coming down at her in his face
zooming in
you know i i don't think
yeah but she said in her in her
interview that he came busting through
the door but like i said it doesn't
really matter because as we will soon
see
this was a dream
oh yeah that's right that's right it was
it didn't it didn't really happen yeah
so they've been in the house for three
months at this point yeah so she gets
woken up
and uh you know by uh billy being like
what the [ __ ] like wake up so it turns
out the whole thing was a dream which
was like a little bit of a fake out or
whatever but tiffany said that it was so
vivid
that she was sure
that
joseph that she saw in her dream
was the spirit that was that she had
been sensing in the house and that he
was trying to communicate with her um
she further says that even though
the ghost was really scary
uh his face also looked really sad she
compared it to she said you know when an
animal is like showing you aggression
but just because it's afraid of you she
said it was kind of like that
um and she said and i kept hearing the
name joseph in my head so i'm assuming
that that's what he's his name was so
yeah so they kind of made it seem like
she really walked downstairs and saw the
ghost standing on the porch
but not really so i guess in real life
she never did actually see him she was
dreaming she was dreaming yeah that's
right and she was and was
convinced that that's what the ghost
looked like that's right
every time she does see him it's a dream
ah she never [ __ ] sees him while
she's awake from all the time he never
appears
or yeah from what i remember maybe yeah
no he never i think that's the only time
the demon appears not him yeah i mean
that's the only time that she sees him
and like i said it's a dream yeah
so tiffany doesn't tell billy about this
because you know she thinks he's gonna
make fun of her
so she goes to the local library and
starts pulling like all the old deeds
for the house
now she finds out that the owner of the
house former owner of the house owned a
you know ran it as a plantation
and that when this owner died
he left the house and the property to
the overseer of the property who was a
freed slave whose name was joseph
now joseph subsequently
got [ __ ] out of this inheritance
by the former owner's relatives who i'm
guessing like sued or came in or
something like that was saying we should
get this house not you
and so they took it away from him just
that story right there what you can
deduce from that i don't know what of
course the laws
depended by county and county
uh it wasn't even state by state it was
just county by county backing back in
the days when slavery was around in the
south um
chances are just that story
my interpretation of that most likely
understanding the culture of that time
joseph was probably the rightful heir
which meant that he was
the owner's son probably but you see
back in those days
depending on the county he probably
couldn't marry his mother
not legally
or
once he was born he wanted it to give it
to his son
but the law wouldn't allow him to
because he was not a married to the
mother which would have made you what
they called back in those days a bastard
child you couldn't have inheritance over
legally wed relatives or you know things
are legitimate be illegitimate so that
that's probably what they're talking
about
that was his dad's place and his dad
wanted him to have it
when he was gone and the other relatives
saw the opportunity come in there and
steal it
that's what it was
like oh wait hold on he wasn't actually
married to the mama they probably got a
they probably got a lawyer and
everything and they go well we can take
it
yeah that's probably what happened
i don't doubt it yeah i don't doubt it
that's probably what happened because
they said he didn't live there very long
and like i said i don't know how true
this story is but he said he didn't live
here very long before the other
relatives came in like little vultures
yeah and took the property away property
and price sold it and [ __ ] divided
the money up i'm sure uh samantha says
just joined what state are we in this is
in uh virginia
franklin virginia is where this house is
um
how did the demon come into play ouija
board satanic worship etc i don't think
we had any of that no it just no blame
the goths on this one yeah it just
emerged on its own it just kind of
emerged on its own perhaps
yeah i don't even think they like said
anything about oh satanists used to live
here or anything like that at the end of
the story there's a an explanation of
what the deal was with joseph we'll get
to it then the guy that witnessed
everything he had his own
theory about what joseph and the demon
but we'll talk about that yeah
so tiffany said that when she went to
the library and saw like joseph's name
like on the deed she was like really
really weirded out because she's she's
like man just the hair stood up on the
back of her neck and she said
she compared finding that out to like a
spiritual experience and she said she
started feeling really bad for joseph
that you know maybe
he's just hanging around this house
because obviously he got [ __ ] out of
it in life so she kind of didn't blame
him for like hanging out there which
like i said i don't
think it
so but she gets real excited so she goes
and tells billy about it and billy again
is a total douche and he's just kind of
like real real dismissive um you know
i've only known this woman for like five
months maybe she has a really overactive
imagination maybe she's crazy maybe this
and that the other
uh so i'm just like okay big help and uh
so she says well maybe the reason that i
have that dream was because i'm supposed
to help joseph somehow
now not long after this though uh [ __ ]
takes a dark turn she's in the kitchen
washing dishes or whatever the [ __ ]
and she said she smelled something like
rotten meat
um and apparently what they did on the
show and
according to the later paranormal
investigators said this was pretty
accurate they said it's so strong that
it like basically made you gag and she
like drives her out of the house
and she goes out and she's like man
something [ __ ] weird and something
like really smells really bad in there
billy gets mad and says hey don't bring
up that weird joseph stuff in front of
georgia because it'll scare her blah
blah blah george was only eight at this
time but tiffany says hey um pretty sure
this isn't joseph this weird thing is
definitely something else something that
doesn't feel human
now
now she's starting to wonder
did joseph actually like send me that
dream because he actually wanted me out
of the house or
was he trying to tell me that this other
scary [ __ ] was in here you know what i
mean like she's not really sure at this
point and she's like maybe that's what
it was maybe he wasn't trying to kick me
out he was just trying to like you know
convey that there's like this other
demonic [ __ ] in here
so uh so billy is just lost patience at
this point he's like nope we're not
talking about it anymore uh you know
just
zip your lips about it
so tiffany at this point said she felt
very isolated because she couldn't
really like talk to him about anything
uh georgia actually senses something is
going on with her but she i don't think
georgia has seen anything at this point
so but she can tell that tiffany is
having some problems
now one night
tiffany says she heard georgia
crying and calling for her dad in the
middle of the night and it sounded like
georgia was right on the other side of
their bedroom door
now she wakes billy up and says hey
georgia's crying and like calling for
you billy wakes up and runs in george's
room but georgia is fast asleep
now he says cause he was interviewed on
the show too like the real guy
he said i didn't hear georgia calling me
so at the time i just assumed that was
kind of another thing where i attributed
it to tiffany being delusional um you
know because now she's hearing my
daughter's voice like yelling for me and
he just thought she was like crazy so
that's this one actually kept kind of a
running tally of like what uh time it
was like when i think they only ended up
staying there for like a year a little
bit more than a year so they said at
this point it's like fall of 2008.
so uh after this billy's awake and he's
kind of grumbling about it so he goes
down to the kitchen to get a beer
and
i'm not sure exactly what happened at
this point on the show it's implied that
he went to get the beer and then he kind
of heard something like a creak or a
footstep or something and he kind of
goes and looks out the back door and he
doesn't see anything and then he turns
around and on the show they kind of have
this like shadow
thing like kind of go shh like that and
then they showed him looking at it and
being like oh [ __ ] and like dropping the
beer bottle and breaking it and then his
eyes go black because i guess he had
blue eyes before and the like the not
the whole they didn't go like full-on
black eyes but just kind of like the the
peoples and the whatever the [ __ ] that
was that was black
so you're led to assume
that whatever this demonic what's this
is in the house has now like possessed
the [ __ ]
so for the next few weeks uh according
to both tiffany and georgia
billy acts completely different
like she tiffany said he was like he
would get angry like that like he was
just kind of like he didn't have any
patience with anything like he didn't
talk to him and he was getting all
[ __ ] ragey about everything and said
it was just not like him at all and she
started to get like afraid of him
um like i said earlier it's no where is
that raccoon but he does come in the
house and like in the hallway outside of
george's room like there's all these
lights on like there's four lights
there's like a couple lamps and like
some other [ __ ] and he's just like who
left all these lights on one two three
he was kind of like that and i was like
oh my god we're having a where is that
raccoon moment um not quite that uh
egregious but it was like along the same
line so i was there for it
so he he's banging on george's door come
on here who left all these lights on and
she comes down and she's like i didn't
leave all the lights out [ __ ] i didn't
turn these on and he's just like look at
all time so you know do you think i made
him money i'm not he didn't say that but
you know what i mean um
yeah george like i said georgia also
said uh yeah he was like not my dad he
was like completely different
tiffany said she barely recognizes him
his eyes looked dark which they say a
lot on those kind of possession things
they said his voice was like all growly
and she was like freaking out because
she's like she didn't really know how to
snap him out of it and like i said she
was kind of getting scared of him
because he was just acting like a rage
monster all the time
so georgia to kind of get away from her
uh lunatic dad she starts going out in
the barn and hanging out with her little
bunny rabbit
but one night she's in there and she
sees
a dark shadow figure she described it as
like the real person she described it as
a shape of a man but all black
so she sees that in the barn
and she says she saw that freaked the
[ __ ] out and ran back to the house
but because there had been so much lack
of communication and so much tension in
the household she didn't tell anybody
about it at the time because
she figured her dad wasn't going to
listen to her anyway so she was just
kind of like whatever
now following this there's actually a
sequence where
tiffany is in the shower and i guess she
thinks she hears somebody like outside
but she kind of like pulls the thing and
like there's nobody there then she comes
out puts on her little robe and she's
like what the [ __ ] and like she hears
something downstairs that kind of sounds
like somebody moving around or banging
or thumping or something
and then there's like a creak behind her
and she kind of like looks behind like
that and then something pushes her like
down the stairs like from she's on like
the first or second step down like from
the top so she kind of goes all the way
down i don't think she was badly hurt
but it looked like it was probably not a
fun time
uh she said like the real lady she said
she very clearly felt hands on the back
of her shoulders shoving her and that it
was like very aggressive that's what she
said and she basically falls all the way
to the bottom like i don't think she
broke any bones or anything like that or
i'm sure they would have said that but
yeah it's
probably like pretty painful i'd imagine
so she's calling for billy to help her
she said she was so scared that
she didn't even want to move she just
kind of like curled up into a fetal
position like at the bottom of the
staircase or whatever
um so billy comes running and actually
whatever it was like i guess like seeing
her
laying there like wounded and terrified
like that like he seemed to like snap
back to normal she said
and um he actually finally believes her
she's like the [ __ ] thing like pushed
me down the goddamn stairs like do you
believe me now and he's like okay i
believe you i believe you and then he
said after that like he felt really bad
that he had been like leaving him you
know her and his daughter like alone in
the house all this time with whatever
the [ __ ] this was so it took her getting
pushed down the stairs for him to like
actually give a [ __ ] about it
so um
i'm being mean uh demon stinks with the
little i like the little pink thing
that's like super cute
um
[Music]
next dimension media said addressing an
earlier question about the shooting
locations it's hampton roads virginia
the production
company is based in suffolk virginia
which is new to dominion pictures okay
yeah because i'm always kind of curious
like where they get their houses from
so at this point uh tiffany calls jackie
tomlin who's also interviewed on the
show at central virginia paranormal
investigations and the team comes out a
few weeks later uh and billy is he gives
it the okay but he's going to be out of
town for work so he's not there
so it's march of 2009 at this point so
the family's been in the house for nine
months
now
one of the first things they do like the
the team goes in there and jackie
basically says she's going around the
camera or whatever and she says to the
entity give us a sign and like the door
like literally immediately like opens up
by itself yeah and then closes by itself
i'm like well that clear enough for you
there you go
and uh then she says
she says something like it showed what a
bold presence it was
now there's actually more to this uh
story which she wrote about on her blog
which i'll get into in a little bit but
yeah they did show that on the show
where she basically said give us a sign
and the door opened and closed by itself
like very very clearly
um but that she said she videoed it but
i couldn't find a video maybe so maybe
there is a video of it somewhere like on
their website like i said i didn't have
a huge amount of time to go through
their whole website but they i did see
one video that they shot in this house
that was kind of like
little piece together stuff and none of
the stuff on there was all that
impressive but
you know i so i don't know if they
actually did uh tape this or not
so the team is there for i guess like 12
hours
i don't know if that's like all at once
or whatever
and uh yeah they confirmed some active
paranormal activity which would seem you
know
yeah you come in there and just say show
me a sign in the door's like
yeah i'm just like yeah there's some
paranormal [ __ ] going on here
um so jackie says i'm pretty sure
there's like a demon in here
and you probably don't want to [ __ ] with
it
and basically
she gives him the very not helpful
advice she's like i i pretty much advise
that you move she's like because
this shit's not good um she's like
there's probably a lot of entities here
but there's one in particular that seems
demonic and you don't want to [ __ ] with
it because it's just gonna get worse and
worse and if if it's already pushed you
down the stairs then obviously it can do
like a lot of physical stuff so you
probably shouldn't mess with it and i
advise you to get the [ __ ] out
um tiffany doesn't want to move though
because other than all of the [ __ ]
going on
um you know she really does love this
house billy loves this house they don't
really want to move so she decides well
i'm not going to tell billy about it
cause like i said he's out of town like
so he didn't know all of that uh going
on
so a few nights after this billy is back
home from wherever the hell he was but
tiffany has not told him again about
what the investigator said because she
doesn't want to move and she's afraid
that you know
that it'll be like bad if she says it
out loud i guess
now suddenly they hear a horse winning
from the barn and tiffany runs out there
to see what the problem is
and she finds that all of the chickens
and ducks and the bunny
are dead
now we were saying like tom even said
well that could have been just like
predators like you know a coyote or
something now i will note though that
billy said on the show the real billy
said they were just laying there dead
with not a mark on him that's what he
said i didn't say coyote though i said
bobcat
a coyote will grab something and just
shake it to death all right it'll leave
marks on it and there and coyote are
kind of big
but man i've seen bobcat get into
chicken coops and just kill every
[ __ ] chicken feathers everywhere but
there's not a lot of marks on them
because
they're cats you know they they love to
[ __ ] play
uh they'll do that [ __ ] even when
they're not hungry
and they kill them by biting them on the
throat suffocating them
you know
and they'll send claws into them but
it'd be hard to find those claw marks
you might find some feathers around but
and they'll they can even get into a
cage
you know a bobcat can can open a door
and get into something yeah they're not
stupid well domestic cats can open
hell pookie can open our cabinets
no problem at all well how long how
would they know they've been around
barns and farms their whole [ __ ] life
you know what i mean you that if they
can open a latch on a [ __ ] door to
get in it that's not the first time
they've opened a latch on a door they've
[ __ ] been doing that
you know probably rated [ __ ] 30 or 40
chicken coops in their lives
and they'll do it when they're not
really hungry
just like pookie will [ __ ] go out
there and just chase lizards you know
kill him
she doesn't do it anymore i think now
it's kind of funny and i think well she
doesn't go outside yeah she's going
outside and if she does go outside she
sees the lizard she doesn't even chase
him i think she got i don't think she
ever wanted to kill him i think she
wanted to play with them she just wanted
to play with them and then they're bored
they're boring now so she's like yeah
no reason to play with them they die
when you play with them like i just play
with them and then they just lay there
yeah
after a little while i realize that it
kills them
but you know they're cats they're that's
what they do they're chasing machines
so probably what happened is this bobcat
got in there just played chase all night
killed everything in there
and if they had a rabbit inside of them
rabbit
pen or rabbit cage they can get in there
or bobcat could
yeah because
i was assuming that the chickens and
ducks were probably just running around
loose so the rabbit was in a hutch but
like i said it wouldn't take that long
and they did also have a horse but
obviously the horse was all right bobcat
wouldn't bother horse at all well no
obviously and like i said they did have
a puppy which like they didn't show on
the show but the puppy actually got hit
by a car yeah
and that was like a little bit later
seen them all or no that was earlier
actually
ultimately dr messed up the timeline dr
matt had a bobcat and he says i want to
wait out here and shoot with my ar-15 i
said dr matt dude
i asked him i said i've asked you if i
could come kill some of these deer to
get into something something to eat man
cars are going to hit these things all
right that's a prey animal but then you
want to come and kill predators i said
you know what i mean they don't have a
law they don't have
you know a a high reprod reproductivity
you know they don't breed in vast
numbers and that made sense to him i
guess he put trapped out and trapped the
bobcat and relocated it leave them
bobcats alone this cat
you know something with coyotes leave
their [ __ ] coyote alone it's a dog
okay
it's a wild dog it's all it is they're
not they're no threat
yeah they can hurt things but there's
not that many of them
let them be well like i said they're not
you know they're they gotta eat too
they're not prey animals they're not so
they don't i mean when they have litters
when they have kids they don't have that
many yeah and they live a long time and
they eat prey animals
and uh they don't have super high
reproductive rates
because they just didn't evolve to be
predated on
deer do they have a good reproductive
rate you know
a male deer that's [ __ ] six years old
is probably sired off [ __ ] you know
five six seven eight
younglings you know
so that's good reproductivity
a deer hunter is supposed to build a
habitat breed deer and just call off the
top
you know you're making deer you're not
killing them
you're making them
like a farmer
and they're free
that's how it's done
planting everything they'd like to eat
you know it's not bait though you can't
bait them but you can plant trees and
rye grass and fruit trees and things and
you just let them breed out there
and pick the older ones
you know and the good hunters have rules
no spikes no four points six point and
above so you at least you know that that
male deer lived three years and then you
can only hunt the does on certain days
during the season you know you go for
the old does
you know they're
kind of tough
but you know you go for those because
then they'll overpopulate if you don't
you got so much food out there
you know then they start [ __ ] cars
start to hit them
and the land can only support so many of
them
yeah i mean you know that's just how
they shake out yeah just how it is
that's part of the system
just let them live and eat them
you take them out [ __ ] fast they
don't know what happens
single shot right to the [ __ ] chest
boom
they just drop like a stone they might
bound off [ __ ] one big leap but they
usually hit the ground dead they don't
even know what happened
you know primitive weapon with bows even
they don't know what happened
i hit one guy with a [ __ ] bow
probably about 25 meters went right
through him and he ran had a poison pod
in it
he ran jumped off the wood line and came
right back
to where i hit him and he smelled the
ground trying to figure out what that
was and then his legs got weak and he
fell asleep he didn't even know what
happened
you know something bit me what was that
went back to see what it was so
evidently it doesn't hurt
i would hope not it's sharp
yeah sharpen a hat real fast
you hear it hit
you know how to get my boat one of these
days i'll show it to him anyway go ahead
all right um yeah so so we don't know
like i said because yeah the chickens
and the bunny and everything like that
were dead but and then they did have a
puppy but like i said the puppy got hit
by a car yeah and the horse wasn't
killed so they were assuming that all
the animals had been killed by the demon
but you know that could go either way
uh obviously though georgia was very
upset at the bunny being i was also very
upset at the bunny being killed and i'm
sure they didn't i mean obviously they
didn't really kill a bunny playing for
the show but you know i was still upset
about it
um georgia said that she knew back then
that the she she called the demon the
man in black that's what she called him
from that time so she said she knew that
he had done that now here's the most
hilarious part of the whole show to me i
loved this so much and it just like made
me laugh out loud
so because the investigators had been
there and [ __ ] seemed to be getting
worse because now their animals are dead
so they call a catholic priest
so he comes to the house and he starts
doing a blessing
so while he's doing the thing
tiffany is telling him
that you know yeah there's a presence in
the house and you know we're glad you
came and it's making us feel very unsafe
like all our animals were killed that
pushed me down the stairs blah blah like
she's telling him about all the stuff
that's been going on but she was like
well he didn't seem like he was really
listening and really didn't seem to
believe them he's just kind of like
going around the house going yeah
blessing the thing and then yeah yep
that's interesting sure oh you know it's
a lot of times it's nothing it's just
people's imagination yada yada he's
saying that kind of crap now while he's
i don't know if this is what really
happened but i hope it is because it's
like super funny
but so while he's doing the blessing
like upstairs like i think it was in
front of george's bedroom door
uh billy said the real one he said the
temperature dropped like it got really
really cold
uh there was that rotten meat smell like
very very strong like just popped out of
nowhere
and george's bedroom door opened by
itself
now on the um the show they showed like
the door opens and then the priest is
looking in there like what the [ __ ] and
then there's like this like
supernaturally kind of wind and then the
door slams shut again
and it's hilarious to me because then
at least like the actors tiffany and
billy are like not even all that phased
and they're just like see that's what we
were telling you about you know what i
mean and it kind of reminded me of that
scene in poltergeist where the
paranormal investigators are there like
all sitting around the table and then
like the lights flash and the family are
like so used to it at this point oh
there'll be another couple in a second
like they always travel in pairs or
something like that like the paranormal
investigators are freaking out so it's
like it reminded me of that so uh so
they're like yeah that's what we've been
telling you about see
like we were telling you and uh the
priest is like yep bless bless bless all
good and then starts like running toward
the front door
saying like yep that's all the house
needs house is fine bye in order to meet
it was uh pretty hilarious i just like
laughed and laughed tiffany said the
real tiffany she said he was in and out
of the house in less than five minutes
like on the show like the actress comes
out on the porch and she was like is
that it like while he's running through
his car and i put the cross on her
handshake
[ __ ] crap
here's some holy water
yeah and then like i wrote down i
actually wrote down the exact quote that
the real billy said
he said rather than stay in battle he
chose to run here's holy water sprinkle
it around the house put the sign of the
cross on your daughter's forehead every
night during prayers and she'll be okay
you know the only way it can hurt you is
if you believe it believe in it and he
said guess what pal things are happening
and we believe yeah so it's like i i
thought that was so funny because like i
wrote it because he was like
the thing about billy was that you know
because he's really on the show he
seemed very much like somebody that
would not make up a story like this like
i'm not saying that all this stuff
happened
he just seemed like a regular southern
guy who's like kind of gruff and
everything so i just thought it was
funny that they saw something that yeah
he was just kind of like guess what pal
like after the [ __ ] priest like ran
away i just thought that was hilarious i
think this is like there was another
episode too where the same thing
happened like where a priest came and
it's just like oh i'm sure it's fine i'm
blessing the house and like some scary
[ __ ] happen and he's like see you bye
you know what i mean so it was that kind
of thing but it's just like it made me
laugh i was like well father karis he's
not that's for sure
uh so for the next few days uh they do
what the chicken [ __ ] priest told them
to do
and it they said it did seem to be
working to some degree to his credit uh
now at this point tiffany said she
started to feel joseph's presence less
and less and she said she hoped that it
was because
that you know the priest being there
briefly had you know made joseph go on
to the next life or whatever um and one
of their theories was that maybe this
other demonic thing
was keeping joseph's spirit there you
know what i mean and that maybe like the
priest being there had actually helped
and like loosen the hold on the [ __ ]
another thing that he said is he thought
that maybe joseph was there to warn them
about it
yeah i mentioned that earlier
yeah
with that
possibility but i don't believe in
demons in the way that they're talking
about here
now you actually define what a demon is
you're talking about an angel
angels can destroy cities and do all
this [ __ ] that's talked about in the
bible
so um
what's it doing [ __ ] around in that
farmhouse that's what i always wanted to
know it's like what unless they're like
some little [ __ ] piddly ass demon
like it's some kind of training
exercises
i think it's more likely something like
a ghost
or one of the kids manifest in
poltergeist activity which is kind of
like a false ghost
but you know
poltergeist activity or psychic
abilities can access the past
maybe somehow the kid that's doing it is
new about joseph who'd been [ __ ] over
in this place
place could have just been a bad place
you know the strong with the dark side
that type of stuff
might have been a ghost the whole thing
might have been
joseph
you know people are kind of dualistic
maybe he had a a good side and a bad
side i mean [ __ ] he got [ __ ] over
he probably grew up in that house
and he was and his dad was gonna give it
to him i bet guarantee that was his dad
which would have been rightfully his but
because of the laws that said that he
wasn't married to the mama the relatives
steal it basically and kick him out of
his own house where he [ __ ] i'd be
corrupted so yeah you're gonna end up
being a [ __ ] ghost going this is my
house i'm gonna haunt this [ __ ] too now
was he actually in there or is it just a
remnant of that aspect of his
personality
you'd only have the only way to know is
to go in there and actually project
yourself into the damn spirit world and
go see
you laugh but i think it's possible
[ __ ] it's happened to me but by
accident just spontaneously
and i imagine if you went to a place
like that and you [ __ ] came out
you gave up the ghost
you'd probably see something weird on
the other side but it probably wouldn't
be anything complicated
it would just have weird effects on this
on this side of the dimension you know
yeah
so after the whole priest debacle uh you
know they did have a few days where
everything seemed like it was fine
and georgia said she hoped at this point
that everything had gone back to normal
but
one night after she gets put to bed
the demon thing like kind of invades her
room it seems like like on the show they
kind of showed it like her it creeping
up behind her
and she said that it said her name she
said that the voice sounded like weird
and altered those were the
words that she used and she said that it
sounded like the voice was right next to
her ear
and then it said her name
now the show actually had the demon
pulling the covers off her and like her
screaming and freaking out and then like
her parents rushing in i don't know if
that really happened because she didn't
say that
but she did say that she heard it like
talking to her um on the show she said
oh the man in black that's what she
called the demon was standing next to
her bed
now tiffany at this point says the fact
that the demon acknowledged georgia by
saying her name
that was kind of like the last straw so
at this point
tiffany and billy have had enough they
pick up georgia i'm assuming it's like
the middle of the night and they just
get the hell out um they had a
three-year lease they said but they just
broke it they'd been there for a little
over a year and they were like [ __ ] this
place and uh billy said i don't even
think i looked in the rear-view mirror
like as they drove away from the [ __ ]
um yeah and he came on and he basically
i didn't write down the exact quote but
he basically said he's like this thing
graduated from footsteps and like
banging on the doors and the windows
to
pushing people downstairs killing every
animal we owned
and he thought i mean he did seem to say
that he thought when the investigators
came that they had stirred it up i don't
know if that's the case or not um but he
said the priest didn't you know didn't
do [ __ ] it didn't help and so he's like
at this point yeah we gotta get the [ __ ]
out so
as i said they had lived there for more
than a year but uh you know they broke
the lease and they just got the hell out
so billy and tiffany they said they got
married in june of 2013. i have no idea
if they're still married or not uh then
they had a little coda at the end where
they said
we had taken some pictures when we like
of us sitting on the front steps of the
house like the first day that they moved
in and they actually hadn't looked at
them uh prior to that
because i guess it was a digital camera
or whatever and they just didn't bother
looking at them they said when they
looked at them later
um
they had there was like the two of them
were on the sitting on the front steps
of the house because i guess georgia
took it and they said like in the window
or the glass door like behind them there
was like a ghostly figure
now they showed like a picture on the
show
but
it was obviously not the real one
because it had the actors in it so i
don't know what the real photo looked
like but they did say about it and she's
she said that billy was like too scared
to look at it so i don't know what the
real one looks like so the house is
apparently still there someone else
lives there now obviously uh but nobody
knows if anything weird goes on there
billy and tiffany tiffany said they
sometimes uh dr drove by the house
occasionally uh just out of curiosity so
this show i think first
um
aired in maybe
2014. i want to say it was 2014
something like that
it's a good episode yeah it's a good
episode this was actually like a much
better episode um
yeah than i remembered uh samantha said
just joined what state are we in wait is
that the same virginia well no it's a
different oh it's okay it's a different
it's virginia
uh what did i say the name of the place
franklin franklin virginia
so as i mentioned i actually found the
paranormal investigator lady jackie that
was on this episode she actually wrote a
big long thing
not too long after this episode aired
where she talked about
uh the actual case the actual
investigation some of the stuff they
didn't show on the show she said that
she thought the show did a really good
job now she says at the end she's like
well
um she's like normally like
you know i don't know how many times
they've been contacted by the show but
she's like usually if you get contacted
by like a paranormal show you're kind of
like wary about it because you don't
know what the [ __ ] they're gonna do with
the story and they're like they usually
[ __ ] it up but she said that she was
actually really happy with how
they did this one i guess because
but the thing about it is that the
paranormal team weren't there the whole
time but so i guess she means she was
happy with how they portrayed
the [ __ ] that happened like while they
were there you know what i mean which
wasn't a huge amount because zach said i
also thought it was weird how the
paranormal team was only in this for a
couple minutes they're usually in there
longer i mean yeah
they were yeah i think they were only
there like i said for 12 hours
i thought the whole thing was the priest
was funnier but you know what i mean
so so this is what uh jackie said
now jackie said that uh tip when tiffany
first contacted her she said she was
like really scared and so was georgia
and she said there was a bunch of
turmoil in the house because of billy
and he didn't believe it at first
and she at this point said there was a
whole bunch of changes that she'd seen
since moving in
and she actually called them after the
animals died she said that her animals
were dying with no explanation i don't
know if that was just one event or if it
was like several events over time um she
does say and this is a quote from her
blog post then this is not uh tiffany
this is the paranormal investigator she
says i can confirm that what you saw on
television were just some of her actual
reports
now uh basically she says when tiffany
first called her she said they uh you
know her company was like really really
slammed and she actually had to put her
on a waiting list she said at which
point tiffany she's like tiffany would
call her like pretty much every day like
hey when the [ __ ] are you guys coming
out here because it's like really bad
um she said that she's like well at
first before i went to the house she was
like i didn't necessarily think she was
crazy
but she's like i thought that she was
maybe scared that i would turn the case
down because she's like we were actually
two hours away from her
um and she said now as the time went on
because i could say she was calling
every day she said she's starting to
come up with some stuff that she was
reporting that made her kind of doubt
the story like she was coming up with
some like amityville horror type [ __ ]
but um but she said well i had already
agreed to take the case so you know i
was gonna do it but like i said we were
backed up so i didn't get out there
until like a little bit later so she
goes to franklin
and uh she you know kind of describes
the house but she said inside the house
was like really nice and everything like
that but she's like it had a feeling
like a really strong feeling of being
watched when you went inside now one of
tiffany's reports that she said that
they didn't talk about on the show she
said when you go through the kitchen
she's like tiffany showed her like all
these flies on the kitchen counter she
said these were
big huge she's like they weren't house
flies and they weren't horse flies
um but they were big
and she's like well i didn't really
think too much about it she's like well
it's a farm and it could be some kind of
thing
um she's like it wasn't exactly a swarm
but she's like it was like 40 of them
like all in one place she said like dead
ones i don't know like just in one place
it was dead ones i guess it was kind of
a situation i'm and i'm just kind of uh
assuming here but i'm assuming the
situation was tiffany was like oh yeah
we have all these weird like dead flies
like turning up just like oh look
there's
some now
and you know so jackie is just kind of
like i didn't think it was weird but i
mean it's weird because it was 40 in one
spot now she said when they went through
the kitchen and out through the barn and
they came back into the kitchen she said
all the flies were gone like all the
dead flies and she's like thought that
was weird okay so there's that
so she also said and i think i mentioned
this earlier she's like yeah she talked
about the rabbit now the rabbit was
still alive when the paranormal
investigator came because she said you
know i went out to the barn and i saw
the rabbit and she said it was this big
rabbit uh biggest one she'd ever seen
they also had a puppy named rebel like i
said and the horse out there uh now she
said the horse
could actually walk from uh the barn
like could go outside and could walk to
the porch on the main house
and tiffany was telling her the horse
does not want to go in the barn anymore
and nothing that you can do will entice
the horse to go back into the barn
because the horse is like scared
something spooked it in the barn that's
yeah but was that around the was that
the bobcat time though i don't know
because like i said at this point the
rabbit was still alive i'm not sure
about the chickens i'm assuming maybe
the chickens were dead i don't know but
the rabbit was still alive because the
paranormal investigator said she saw the
rabbit
i had a pony that would not get in the
wash rack because because it had rubber
mats
and i have no idea why
remember tiger
lily oh yeah i remember tiger lily would
not step on robert rubber mats for some
reason scared of him oh she wouldn't go
to he had to wash her outside the
wash rack
and i tried everything and she couldn't
get her on there she just nope
not going in there she thought she was
going to fall or something
huh
weird well never seen me about it i
associated those looking rubber mats
with something
yeah it must be some kind of like really
bad association and it must be maybe
from like when she was young and
something like that and i really liked
it she had never seen anything like it i
know
but you know like i said animals make
associations just like children do and
they
they're really really hard to shake off
so yeah so the horse she said the horse
didn't want to come in the barn
now uh jackie said that within 72 hours
of her first coming out to the house the
rabbit was found dead in the barn with
no explanation
uh shortly thereafter the puppy ran from
the house down the driveway and got run
over by a car so the rabbit didn't die
at the same time that the chickens did
no
yeah that's what i mean like yeah the
show implied that all the animals died
at once
but just from the way she's talking
i'm i'm assuming that either summer all
of the chickens and the ducks died
because
jackie said that tiffany kept calling
like before she went out there she said
tiffany kept calling me and saying oh my
animals are dying without explanation
but by the time that jackie got out
there the rabbit was still alive and the
dog and the dog the rabbit was big
though the rabbit might have been pretty
up there at age you know
it's hard to say you'd have to do an
autopsy to know for sure yeah
very rare that
paranormal stuff kills animals
yeah i mean that would be really [ __ ]
up if that happened
so so yeah so the so the rabbit was dead
within 72 hours she said no explanation
uh she says upstairs in the master
bedroom uh there was a feeling of actual
oppression that's what she called it um
and she said that she had done some like
audio recorded some audio that day like
an evp type thing and she said when she
played it back
uh she heard like some unexplained heavy
breathing
and that there was no one in the house
at the time but her and tiffany
and another thing too is that when she
first met
billy
um she said that he seemed very gruff
and she said she didn't remember if her
eyes if his eyes were blue or dark or
whatever because it was a whole thing
about oh he's possessed and like his
eyes went dark or whatever
but she said um she's like i can't
really recall what color his eyes were
that day she's like but i did meet him
again when we were in the boardroom or
the conference room at new dominion
pictures when they were working on the
um you know on the episode and she said
you know i noticed his eyes were blue
and she said he seemed completely
different than the first time i'd met
him and he didn't remember having met
her before
that's what she claimed anyway
so like i said they're trying to imply
that he was possessed the first time i
don't know if that's true or not but
that's what she said
um so as i mentioned they uh the photos
that they took like on moving day they
reviewed them later on and said there
was like a face in the window like
behind them
um and she apparently said that it
hadn't been tampered with i don't know
what the actual photo looks like i
didn't show the actual because the only
one they showed on the show was like the
the fake one you know so there's that
um as i said they actually even though
they said on the show that tiffany did
her own uh research into the history of
the house and found out the stoke about
joseph and everything uh jackie said
that her and her friend linda silk who
lived in sussex virginia uh pulled the
deeds themselves
and they wanted to find out like as much
as they could they said that somewhere
in the land there was an old family
cemetery uh on that on that as well and
also i don't think they mentioned this
on the show but she said that everybody
that had lived in the house prior like
everybody that rented it uh didn't
usually stay longer than a year like
they would always leave
um another thing that jackie brought up
was that
on the morning of the investigation uh
her daughter who is also like the
co-founder of this uh paranormal
investigation team uh she was fine but
when they got uh to the house or started
like on loading or unloading equipment
she started getting sick and stayed sick
for the entire investigation
um
they said that also there was kind of a
bunch of like electrical anomalies that
happened at the house uh tiffany called
them and said the heat uh was out and
that when they did the investigation
they actually had to use like space
heaters and the wood stove because the
heat wasn't working
and billy was out of town and i guess
they couldn't take care of it
when they got there too the power was
out in the barn also with no explanation
um they also said that while they were
setting up their uh equipment four of
the investigators and jackie were uh
unpacking equipment and they said a very
very strong cold breeze came into the
room like so cold that you could see all
their breath it was that um and they
said yeah it was kind of cold because
there wasn't heat but they had like the
wood stove and everything going so it
was 65 degrees it was supposed to be
um uh so there was that and there here's
remember what i said about like when she
first on the show when she first goes
into the house and she says show me a
sign and the door opens she's like okay
actually tiffany had told them
that there is a door and it's like a
door to like a crawl space like under
the second like the stairwell
and she said that door opens on command
so uh
so she said yes so she said well i gotta
check that [ __ ] out so she says um
so i go in there i stood four feet away
from the door and asked it to open
it did more than once
so they didn't even so i don't know if
that's true or not but like i said they
they showed on the show just like show
us a sign but she's like april's like i
opened the door and it opened and
apparently like it did it over and over
and i guess it had been doing that
before that because she said tiffany
reported that before we went there that
the door would open if you told it to
tiffany also said that the bathroom off
the dining room had a light that would
come on uh she'd had electricians in but
they couldn't find anything uh to it
and she said it was very quick like
someone just flipped the switch and i
actually did see video of this because
they posted a video of it on their site
it's not like super impressive but it is
like a little bit weird like they are
kind of like shooting they're not
shooting in the bathroom it's kind of
like back here and like the bathroom's
kind of the back and you kind of do see
the light go like
and like go on and off like really quick
like that and there's nobody around so
there's that
now remember how i said that she was
reporting amityville horror stuff okay
this is what i'm talking about uh
apparently there was like gunk oozing
from the walls yes like in the
amityville horror uh so tiffany had
reported
that uh that there was stuff
coming out of the walls
and uh they didn't really believe her at
first but they said that it did happen
while they were there they said it
looked like what she described what
jackie described it she said it looked
like cairo syrup with a yellowish
brownish tint she said it wasn't just
like a drip here and there it was like a
lot it was just kind of like a cross a
wall and it was like big drips and it
would start it at the seam in the
ceiling so they said they went up to
check the uh the floor upstairs and like
they went under the house they were
trying to like figure out what it was
and they couldn't figure out what it was
and then they went back to film it and
it was gone as if it had never been
there
so they said they couldn't collect any
of it which like i said convenient
that there's no
evidence left behind that's what i'm
saying
um a couple other things they reported
were kind of like um
weird uh audio anomalies they said that
sometimes like they'd be recording stuff
and like when
like when the audio recorder was in
record mode it would start playing
earlier recordings like back to them
which they thought was like really weird
they said that happened a couple of
times uh like it would play their own
voices back to them even though it was
supposed to be recording and not playing
so they said that was pretty weird
um let's see there was some stuff with
the heat i don't even know what that was
um yeah she said the the horrible smell
she said they the show did a wonderful
job on that reenactment
um they said
tiffany never reported the smell from
the dining room she said but when we
were in there the team was in there
doing an audio session she said we
smelled it and she said it wasn't a case
of you know hey do you smell that she's
like it was very very strong and pungent
and nauseating that's what she said uh
she said it smelled like rotten meat or
a dead body
um she said that
they did a bunch of evps they said they
could never deny or confirm the presence
of joseph she said but i can state that
the only audio captured on the entire
investigation was during the questioning
of joseph like the only evps that they
got so i don't know if they said
anything that was all that clear
she didn't see what the ebps were no and
like i said i listened to some like i
said they have there's like little bits
of video and stuff like that but some of
the stuff i can't really tell like what
is it what it says or anything like that
um
let's see
uh one of the investigators on the team
she said one of the he's like a huge
huge skeptic and he said while he was in
the master bedroom he felt as though
someone poured a cold pitcher of water
down his shirt collar and he was like
really freaked out by it and couldn't
figure out what had happened
also said they also went out to the barn
like that evening
they said there was no power out there
and they didn't uh catch any emps
um but she said they had a lot of
electrical problems out there like all
the digital cameras and like some of us
all began to like power off like at the
same time like uh inexplicably um and
then
she's like they did it a couple times
like over the course of the evening and
they still kept having problems like the
[ __ ] kept shutting off for no reason
she said the last time they went out
there she said let me see if i can
describe this we felt small as if what
was in there was larger than life itself
she also said they felt threatened
uh so there was that and she was saying
they tried to entice the horse into the
barn and the barn she said she said the
horse looked at them like they were
crazy like no [ __ ] way am i coming in
there you know they couldn't get the
horse to cup in there so there was that
uh they also took a picture and i saw
the picture like i said it's not all
that impressive but they took a picture
inside the barn
that seems to show some kind of shadowy
something or other that like could be
a figure it could be somebody's shadow
it could be lots of things like it was
kind of like ambiguous but they did put
the photo of it like up on the thing
um also she said they got a lot of
camera interference uh there's that
uh there was another bit of video that
they got that i looked at again not
super impressive none of these ever are
but it's just kind of like they were
film i couldn't even tell what they were
filming it was just kind of like the
corner of a room or something and then
like all of a sudden this
thing comes in it looked like she calls
it the flame and i guess you could call
it that but it does kind of look like
this weird light that's kind of red like
reddish orange like kind of comes in
like thin like that like
like that so it looked weird but
i don't know if i'd be like oh that's
paranormal it was video
i think it yeah i think it was video was
it video or was it a photo i can't
remember the frame because she made a
video where she put together like clips
of video from the investigation and
still photos from the investigation
she's sitting there smoking and a little
[ __ ] ember came off her cigarette
went out in front of the camera no no it
was it was bigger than that bigger than
that like it looked bigger than that
okay i mean i'm not saying it was
paranormal i don't it probably wasn't
but i'm just saying that it was weird
looking but i don't know like what it
was
necessarily and then she says the bread
okay i saw the video of this too
now
this video uh they said it took place in
the kitchen early in the morning when
they were you know uh wrapping up the
investigation they were packing up all
their stuff but they still had one of
the cameras on like in the kitchen and
they just kind of had it facing like
toward there was like the stove and
there was like a table in the foreground
and the table in the foreground had like
a bunch of [ __ ] on it and then like it
had like a a loaf of bread that was like
in a wrapper still and it was just kind
of like on the edge
now uh she said nobody had been in the
kitchen for a couple of hours at this
point because it was very early in the
morning
and the bread
i couldn't really tell what i was
looking at she said
that the end of the bread like the um
yeah the end of the packaging of the
bread is like unraveling which it does
kind of look like that now that i'm
thinking about it and she said you can't
really see it all that much from the
video but she said the bread actually
kind of tilts off the table as well now
as i said i watch it's not super
impressive like i said
but
it does look like something weird is
going on at the end of that bread
like of the packaging it looked like
because i'm sitting there looking at
them like what am i looking at like
she said it was unraveling which maybe
it was i don't know i don't know if
there was a twist tie on it or not like
maybe somebody just went like that and
it suddenly decided it could see real
well you couldn't really see it all that
good it almost to me it almost kind of
looked like the end and i don't know
maybe it just was a optical illusion but
it almost kind of looked like the end of
the loaf of bread was kind of going like
that okay you know what i mean maybe but
but it was like so subtle i couldn't
really tell but weird either way it was
yeah it was kind of weird looking it was
kind of weird like i said not super
impressive but a little bit weird a
little bit weird um now she says there's
a notable noticeable swirl beside it you
can see it by the stove i didn't really
see that i guess i know what she's
talking about but i didn't really notice
it
um
and uh so there was that
she also says i don't know if this has
anything to do with the thing but she
says the day after they were at the
house
one of the investigators uh said they
had four cats two of the cats got sick
and had to be taken to the vet one of
them had to be put down
um
[Music]
and she says she felt really shitty like
after that too like her daughter was
sick and that she felt really shitty
like lethargic
um another investigator that was there
uh also called to say he was sick
and then another one called and said
they were sick and then the skeptical
one i'm assuming this is the guy that
said that he felt uh cold water down his
back of his neck or whatever says uh i'm
going to the doctor i have a really bad
migraine so apparently everybody got
like really sick after they went to this
house
and then another buddy another one calls
i don't know how many people she has on
her team but it's a lot
so another one calls and says
um
two of both of my dogs are sick and i'm
taking them to the vet uh or no one of
the dogs was sick and shook him to the
vet the other one like ran away
and then jackie said that her dog
is
like freaking out like trying to dig
through the bottom of the bathtub and
[ __ ] like that they said which that dog
never did before so everybody's animals
were acting weird or getting sick and
all the people are acting weird and
getting sick so they uh attributed that
to the investigation
she says um that she reached out to a
demonologist bishop james long in
kentucky
and uh basically i guess because
they didn't really show this on the show
but i think according to what i mean
from what i could
glean from what she said was that jackie
said oh you should bring in a
demonologist but i guess maybe tiffany
said no because she wanted to stay in
the house or i don't really know but
they said that they didn't really decide
to bring the demonologist in but she
said she did contact him in kentucky
like talk to him about this case
uh so there was that
and uh basically
she says everybody asked me did i really
tell them to hey move out uh she's like
yes i absolutely did and she said this
is the
and this is right from her blog she said
this is the first and only case i have
ever stated that to anyone that they
should just move out the [ __ ] house
so uh so yeah at the end she basically
just says um that when she got called to
do the show she was like very skeptical
because paranormal shows will usually
like uh you know exaggerate stuff or
like make it and she was like really
happy that that didn't happen uh so she
really liked how this show turned out
um so basically that's
she says this is what she says at the
end
she says um
by choice we release very little on
demonic cases we are seeing trends to
them as in other cases however the last
thing i need is everyone yelling it's a
demon to get on tv
these cases are rare but they do happen
um so you know that's basically what she
said about that so
they didn't do you know and then she
says at the end the house on television
is not the actual house which like i
said they don't usually but
you know what year did this occur uh
2008 2008. so not that long ago actually
yeah in the grand scheme of things some
of these are back in the 70s from this
series
yeah well like i said this season was
2014 so some of these i feel like they
tried to get more recent kind of stuff
okay i thought it was a good episode
um is there anything else you want to
talk about
i guess not because that was kind of
like all like i said that was pretty
much i tried to find the real house
maybe one of y'all can find it but you
want something to eat
yeah would you want some grits
uh
okay yeah with bacon and cheese i
thought you were gonna make bread today
i never got around to it man i wasn't
feeling good today okay yeah he just
kept saying less because sometimes like
at night he'll be like oh i should make
some bread and i'm like don't forget
about it because yeah i say i'm gonna
make cookies yeah and then ain't never
yeah
i'm not feeling that well so i want to
make something that's like a quick and
easy like one dish you know
yeah
do we have like anything to put in them
like eggs or anything yeah i can hard
boil some eggs yeah that'd be good okay
all right so hold on uh tim said i've
lived in virginia for about three months
and horse flies are here but rare and
never like going in the house usually
stay in the backyard yeah we have horse
flies here as well um they said it
wasn't horse flies though yeah she said
it wasn't horse flies and it wasn't
house-like she wasn't really sure what
they were some kind of big fly i've seen
those in egypt
they don't really have them here but the
thing is is that she couldn't collect
them she said they disappeared
i wasn't there
which like i said that seems i'm not
saying they're lying i'm just saying
it's a little convenient i had [ __ ] and
[ __ ] poultry guys [ __ ] house
disappear yeah but we also can't we also
capture stuff pieces of toilet paper
with drops of blood on it got pictures
got pictures of things that had arranged
but nothing conclusive you know what i
mean
i mean i got photographs of [ __ ]
pillows and [ __ ] patterns you're like
why are you taking pictures of pillows
and patterns you had to be there to
understand why we feel like because i
didn't do that [ __ ] that's why yeah
yeah tim says i'd be out of there if
aunt jemima syrup was coming out of the
walls jeez yeah yeah i kind of feel like
as soon as stuff starts seeping out of
the walls and i knew that it wasn't
you know just like a [ __ ] pipe burst
or something like that i'd be like yep
that's some demonic [ __ ] bye all right
so uh we will be back again tomorrow
evening talking about a movie probably i
don't know which movie we're gonna do
because i don't know what we're gonna
watch later yeah but we were saying that
we should probably do godfather two this
week but i don't know we've got a
sicario part two or sicario too so we
might do cardio two is probably faster
it might be shorter and shorter we'll
have to like look at the run time to see
because i don't want to be like falling
asleep at the end uh danny rowling said
we should do chud
and if we do that we'd probably have to
do chad too bud the chud yeah but which
i haven't seen since i was a kid but
yeah so we'll be back tomorrow talking
about another movie thank you everybody
for dropping by on this haunting mondays
and we'll see you again tomorrow evening
bye